video games they're back
post-apocalyptic video games are back no
longer you have to keep playing Tokyo
jungle because for therefore its back on
consoles and PC Peter Brian and Alexa
ray Korea how you doing hi good
isn't it nice people talk about fall
right now I know yeah but I still can't
talk about like the plot stuff that I
want to talk about because no one in the
offices finished that [ __ ] that's eating
me up but yeah it's good to actually
like have something to say about the
game in a public way and people have a
lot of opinions about my opinion do they
some people do we'll keep waiting
spoilers for most of this well for all
of this hopefully 9 to 10 on gave all
calm hands up if you love and follow
that for ya bunch of people in the
audience as well this games great I'm
loving it and what is it the sort of
grab G Peter what's your experience at
the Fallout franchise and what wasn't
about for you really loved fallout 3 was
my first game in the series I kind of
dabbled in like the original but yeah I
put in probably I'd say about 30 hours
of fallout 3 which is almost nothing
compared to people who are like hardcore
fans of the series and forgave me a lot
of what I loved about 3 and that is
obviously a lot of opportunity to
explore discover things be surprised by
characters and to sort of shape a story
that has a lasting impact Alexa did you
live in Boston for a couple years I
lived in Boston for six years six years
tell me about what you think of the
world of Fallout 4 it was sort of I I
don't know if anyone who actually lives
in Boston can chime in in the comments
here but like walking through Boston and
walking through like like the like
Fenway is not like a shitty town and
like it's it's sort of hurt a little bit
it's like all this no it's like all
crapped up like it was it was definitely
very it was very poignant for me to sort
of walk around and explore I did a lot
of exploring but it was really cool to
see their vision of like the
post-apocalyptic wasteland in this like
very very like smart city and the whole
like it's the Institute thing it was
also really cool how they sort of took
MIT which was which is working on secret
crap all the time making it this like
big thing it's interesting because it's
a plot point in three as well that a
little bit New Vegas that I guess the
the replicated man are wonderful quite
in Fallout 3 you can see some of that
sort of appearing here interesting you
say that because that when I played
Assassin's Creed syndicate are it made
me feel nostalgic in that London oh it's
not one of those things and what did you
think about the world building in
fallout 4
I appear I thought it was really good
overall it started off very abrupt hmm
you know like we saw a deathclaw earlier
you know 15 minutes into the game you're
fighting that thing yeah and it's like
okay I guess we're really like doing
this you know so yeah there wasn't this
really abrupt start and this transition
from your life as a as I put it in my
review I guess a well-to-do guy from
like a 1950's desk area lady lady
correct into this wasteland where like
you know anything goes and whatever you
gotta do to survive is the way to be but
you know as it goes on you begin to meet
characters from the various factions
that are keeping Boston afloat as it
were as a society although not very well
and navigating that to me gave me a
great sense of the overall community
within the game and by the end of it I
was totally invested in the lives of
everybody I'm totally with you on the
the initial couple of hours of this game
are also they're kind of jarring in a
weird way that so much stuff is dumped
on yourself stuff that you sort of earn
in the older games like very early on
and I was kind of weirded out by in
those past games at least in three new
vegas of the earlier ones the to
isometric ones as well is that you sort
of you start in an isolated place they
eventually you find the big sort of
populous area or is in this you actually
spend most of the start of the game in
the city yeah and I get you know you can
play whichever way you want but it
wasn't until my later hours where I
started to go ahead and finding that
wilderness yeah where I was like oh no
this map is actually really big and
there's like stuff hidden all over the
place a lie those old games as well yeah
I don't know I think that big dumping in
the beginning kind of adds to the sense
of what fallout 4 is like you're in
frozen here's a wasteland find your baby
go and I think kicking you out of the
gate with very little here's how you do
it I think sort of ad set experience
it's very much like it it adds to that
idea that this is an extension of what
fallout 3 and new Vegas where it's I
think a much more accessible game for
people who are familiar with those
titles
perhaps there are some hurdles that
newcomers have to overcome but you know
but then there's also the idea that it
ramps up the actions so fast that it
kind of prepares you for the worst in
those opening moments so yeah I feel two
ways about that intro and this is some
footage some gameplay I caught over the
weekend of just the general shooting and
one of the great things about this game
is that you can play this game but
without that's completely but it's a
fairly competent shooter in its own
right right it's simple and functional
you know and you know if for me it was
more of a like a reactionary thing if
there was someone barreling towards me I
would just put a couple rounds into them
rather than jumping into vats to like
you know plan out every single shot so
for me it was more of a utility than
like a means to enjoy the game but but
yeah it's better than it wasn't three
let's talk about some of the new I guess
features they've been added to the game
and some of which seemed almost like
loose ends the base building settlement
stuff I've been enjoying using it
because it's it's kind of a nice side
activity to do like all that junk you
feel like is going towards something
yeah it doesn't really seem to kind of
do anything even when you set up trade
rats right yeah I mean what the trade
routes are good if you really value
repurposing the junk you find to create
stuff because then you can store things
and one part of Austin and access them
in another mmm it's convenient you can
also fast travel if you want to get to
the other stuff so it's not like it's
you know inventing some new ability at
large but yeah like the settlement stuff
didn't really draw me in and I think
it's because you know I've I've gone
into Fallout 2 to do the exploration
than discovery in the combat and to pull
me away from that I need something
that's really rewarding or challenging
this to me was neither of those things
you could you know people there's like
some small side quests to people like
hey we really need some beds and maybe a
roof it doesn't matter how you slap that
together yeah they're just like sweet
I'm gonna go take a nap thanks here's
plenty experience points if you put six
beds at in the middle of like a yard
fine
yeah and if you look at a game like
fortnight right that is a game I don't
think it's out yet right I think maybe
it's just in beta that's you can use it
on them yeah I mean that is a game
built around this idea and an idea that
was sort of taken from games like
minecraft in a way but but in for
tonight you know you can take things in
your environment repurpose them and then
you put all that to the test and then it
really becomes focused and you know
around what you've built and I guess
maybe in light of that this didn't feel
that great and in light of their other
content it wasn't compelling to me it's
completely optional all right you don't
actually add for anything there's some
stuff you have to do later using the
same interface but it's not in the vein
of building a settlement it's a no vein
of constructing something to help
someone accomplish a thing cool nice and
vague I like it Alexa so I'm almost done
I know peter is almost done I've sort of
I sort of wandered off and started doing
a bunch of side stuff I sort of really
liked the idea of you like running along
in this wasteland looking for like your
kid I know a lot of people are like oh
captured infant subplot but it's so
interesting like like you you're you
don't know where you are in the timeline
when you unfreeze so in your head like
I'm thinking like oh like it's still a
baby
yeah wait a minute no is it like an
adult yeah who knows right yeah what if
it's actually 200 like he was stolen at
the outset and he's like dead and all
his grandchildren are like you've no
idea kind of don't know right so you're
looking for this person that you don't
know what they look like you don't know
what they're called and it's just like I
don't know and I did it as a woman so I
liked this idea of like having this like
deranged mother running around the
waistline becoming this terror looking
for her kid yeah I actually prefer the
female voice acting and quite a lot is
this I thought this was before the
nuclear apocalypse Wow
that's oh there you go ooh that's my
comes a mustache I see a hair line you
gotta get a mustache in there Oh No Oh
fire Kelly we're all beautiful we are
all Thornberry looks like yeah there we
go
nailed it yeah I prefer the the the
female voice actor it also kind of yeah
it felt a little bit more real like
mother running after child rather than
because if I don't know the father the
dude I don't know especially he looks
like this disaster I don't know it
doesn't come across as earnest and for
I'm gonna talk about my quest little bit
let's go for me I think that you know so
many people I talk to love the side
stories and I found a lot of them to be
very interesting but as the main quest
went on and especially in the final act
of it man do things just come together
in a way that you you really didn't see
coming over and and it drags other
people into the line of fire that you
have you know befriended or helped in
certain ways and you're forced to make
choices that it's like you're set you're
always like making a sacrifice I'm
trying to imagine that there is a way to
play this where you don't have to
sacrifice anything or anyone but I can't
see it but I can see a lot of ways where
the what you sacrifice changes and that
to me was like I'm sitting there like
man this decision I'm about to make and
then afterwards like man I really want
to know what else would have happened
like more than the sidequest stuff the
main quest wants makes me want to play
the game more and again yeah from the
start I'm not as far as either of you
and on the main quest stuff I'm mostly
done side stuff and but I have to agree
I think this is probably it's I think
it's the best main course since the
series went 3d I know for threes main
quest was kind of not really that great
and you went through the same places a
lot it was kind of short you can
complete a pretty short a new Vegas was
interesting because I had all the
different you know organizations you
could join inside wouldn't why not but
it was still kind of a little bit benign
at the end so is there a lot of like
sighting with different specific
organizations and all that sort of stuff
yeah and there's no for some of them
it's like okay this is obviously a good
person this is a bad person or faction
but those lines become blurred the
further you get into the story and
you're choosing sides or you don't want
to like it's it's so tough it's so tough
like right up until the vit 2 till the
final minute you're just racking your
brain what do I do like what's more
important to me what do I value the most
and you know the game I don't think this
is spoiling things too much because we
already know the Institute is involved
and people know the Institute is
involved in creating cyborgs essentially
and it sort of raises these questions
like similar to you know themes that
come up in Blade Runner yes which is
probably more popular than Do Androids
Dream of Electric Sheep the source are a
lot of this
these discussions but you know you deal
with sort of deciding like you know what
is human like at what point you know
when someone's looking at you and
pleading for something and you've
traveled with them but they're a robot
you know how do you how you ever decide
like no all of that doesn't matter yeah
but you you come to a point where you
have to make a few of those decisions
and that's that I was surprised I did
not see that plot line coming at all
cool in this game all right
looking forward to hearing more about
that and let's talk a little bit we're
gonna get Jeff on into the grossman on
from John Baum in a sec to talk about
sort of glitches and how they enter into
the review process and I've had a bunch
of glitchy [ __ ] happen I think maybe
like 30 hours on different consoles and
stuff and but nothing that like it's a
weird thing we're like I kind of I'm
expecting this almost from a bethesda
game whether rightly or wrongly and how
did the glitches and the sort of
problems with framerate or bugs and why
not factor into your review played the
vast majority this game on PlayStation 4
I noticed the framerate drop a few times
it was not a frequent thing at least to
the point where it was really noticeable
to me the glitches themselves that they
they exist and they're funny
they make me laugh it breaks immersion
in that sense and it's not commendable
I'm not gonna say good job if ESDA for
shipping a buggy game that's what we
love it characterizes some of their
games that are like fallout but the
important things that I was discussing
before and even the moment-to-moment
action and storytelling exploration
stuff that trumped any glitch that I saw
like yeah I'd laugh I'd laugh them off
it doesn't mean they don't exist but
they don't actually to matter to me so
you know the the score of the game got
was not it wasn't like it was a 10 and
because there were glitches it was a 9
mm it earned the 9 the glitches just
happened to exist within that that
paradigm cools I Peter Brian x-ray Korea
thank you so much coming on talking
about fall that far and there was no
shortage of for ty for contact non-gang
so I thought con right now and we've
been playing this for obviously over a
week so far I know a bunch of content up
on the side content got a company by
said that word videos is [ __ ] for you to
check out on games fine YouTube so I go
do that if you want more fallout 4
goodness
[Music]